I hate intros one punch man season one
Dragon Ball Z character shows up starts
carpet bombing the city knocks out some
heroes don't think they were
top-of-the-line but still cueball
Saitama has to intervene he saves a girl
explains his motives triggers blue boy
and then kills it all while being pissed
at his Oh penis we get some lore from
three years ago when Saitama was
confronted with a spongebob crossover
episode he has the eyes of a married
person so the crab lets him off the hook
to go hunt for a big trend kit Saitama
runs into five balls and learns that
Larry was looking for the kid because he
drew nipples on him while he slept
Saitama decides it's not any of his
business but when Larry shows up he
instinctively saves the kid the kid lost
his ball leaving him with the four he
was born with Larry can't forgive the
nipples while Saitama states a fact and
gets thrown across the courtyard he
comes back from war gets smacked around
then rips out Larry's eye which just so
happens to be connected to all of his
vital organs back to the present massive
body builder drinks homemade start rose
from his scientist brother Saitama just
wants a chat so we lands on his shoulder
but the scientist tells his brother to
kill him big boy guesses the brown
shoulder and kills his brother instead
Saitama seems to get a kick out of this
and then proceed someone shot him he's
kind of a downer and does it feel
anything like me in high school he has a
wet dream that wakes up to disappointing
reality also like me in high school
yep - so - Saitama is getting smurfed on
robbery ends up getting sucked off not
like main high school where we get
introduced to Genesis in pursuit of a
succubus like villain with profound
one-liners the time I was focusing on
his yb1 accidentally runs into the
ongoing fight
genna's makes quick work of the swarm
but is shocked to see that Saitama
survived the bus code changing the case
a new level of power so sucky bus starts
giving it to Jonas he feels like he's
lost so he's planning on
self-destructing by Saitama bitchslaps
are out of existence which is the only
slap he does in the whole show I guess
the only female villain what an
old-fashioned guy after this disability
of power Jenna's wants to become his
disciple so he heads over to saitama's
house and starts monologuing about how
he's looking for a cyborg who destroyed
its town we get a first look at the
house of evolution who had sent the
succubus and caught footage of the slab
so they send some mutant birds to go
bring him in now after Saitama deals
with the strong set the bunch and makes
an internet meme the last survivor falls
in line pretty quick episode 3 we get
some backstory on the guy who's running
the house of evolution after learning
about this Saitama and jet hose head
there to prevent any further abduction
attempts dr. Janus learns that they're
coming so he prepares traps as well as
the secret weapon all the traps are
negated by Janus when he blows up the
building leaving just the basement to
explore the trump card is beetle boy
carnage Kabuto who sucker punches Jonas
wait he challenged his Saitama to a
fight in their fight experimentation
room Jonas jumps in but his no match get
smacked up and turned into a budget Bob
Ross now it's I Thomas turn beetle boy
goes to attack but immediately righted
by his fierce presence Saitama takes a
minute to explain to everybody how he
got so strong which ends up pissing off
budget Bobby dude oh boy goes final form
an uppercut Saitama then gets one shot
sparing enough time to make a sale at
the grocery store which leaves the
doctor alone to ponder his left choices
Yepez owed for skin had all my shows up
and starts making a lot of good points
but doesn't address the problems and the
healthiest of ways he targets any rule
because he's the wealthiest man in town
Saitama doesn't care until he finds out
hammerhead and his entourage are all
bald and giving bald guys a bad name so
he goes out to stop it bicycle beta
makes first contact and gets one tap
president choi makes his appearance and
employs sonic to stop hammer head you
find Simon stars popping off heads like
their GI Joes until Jess hammer had his
lot to get stoned by Cunha thankfully he
has a thick skull and escapes running
into Saitama hammerhead reminds him of
his childhood self so he just dismantles
to suit by ends up letting him live I
thought my runs into Sonic who attacks
him because he's balding assumed to be
with hammerhead sonic launches another
attack by accidentally gets wrecked by
Saitama
we assume Sonic is foreign because that
doesn't appear to be an Asian bulge he
swears his revenge and then dips
so tell me realizes that nobody knows
about him as a hero because he is
unlisted in the hero registry so him and
genna's go to take a test at the hero
Association to get registered yepez owed
5 Saitama and Jenna's both ASA fitness
test by Saitama I got horrible scores on
the essay portion so he's classified as
a rank C hero while Genesis rank s
select rise flexing on Saitama because
he doesn't want to get out ranked by him
and wants to put him in his place
I'd like to think that Saitama busted
out the crane technique while I made
short work of him Janos tries as far
with Saitama to I understand more about
his power it's as close as you'd expect
by Janus gets his revenge in an udon
eating contest and that's when they were
approached by the class a ranked one
hero sweet mask
Jonas assumes that he wants to fight but
he's just there to give an eerie welcome
to the hero Association and finally
Janos since Saitama take their
relationship to the next level by moving
in together
episode 6 Jonas explains that c-class
heroes who have no hero activity for a
week will get removed from the register
which the FBI watchlist work like that
because there are no major incidents is
occurring he has to go and look for
smaller crimes like robbers and purse
snatchers while he's running around
looking for something new reveals
another hidden power did you see it easy
up skirts if the hero thing doesn't work
out he can always become a content
creator I was thinking something like
bald warrior
well while searching key is again
approached by Sonic wanting rematch but
before anything can happen a woman
mistake Saitama for a villain tank top
tiger goes to take him
while stealing my extremely original cue
ball joke yeah I'm not gonna rerecord
that so here we are I would make fun of
his appearance but he heart committed
with the eyebrow dying and everything if
only everybody shared that presence of
mind
sonic takes out tank top to keep Saitama
to himself then attacks the city until
Saitama hits him with the classic judo
chop a new wife who enters is afraid for
my heart we get a look at a reformed
hammerhead cosplaying me when this
channel fails class a hero spring
mustachio is accompanied by Golden Bob
which let's be honest sounds like an STD
to investigate part of City Z that's
uninhabited due to a high amount of
monster attacks or hentai vibes emerge
when we run into a new monster who's
clearly stronger based on the pupil
dilation we can assume a mix of LSD and
heroin they see a monster I see my
brother
Saitama lives nearby and is walking home
and ends up eating the monster rumors
start to spread about the horrifying
monster in city see while Saitama moves
up to rank 342 after defeating Sonic
Episode seven Jonas is summon along with
other as class heroes to stop a meteor
heading towards cities
he meets silver Fang who was one of the
only heroes to show up and metal knight
who was just there to flex and test his
new weapons but stay safe in a room to
avoid any consequences hmm metal night
shoots off rockets which don't amount to
anything so now Genesis up he wears his
heart on his sleeve and pokes at the
meteor which fails as well Saitama shows
up and breaks the meteor but debris
still destroys a lot of the city nobody
dies in all three heroes receive credit
moving Jonas up to s 16 metal knight up
to s 6 and Saitama up to c5 we learn
about what threat levels there are Tiger
massive loss of life
there's demon threatening destruction of
a city dragon which is disruption of
multiple cities I don't know when what
world two dragon would be worse than a
demon but maybe that's just me and
finally God level which is the threat of
human extinction the tank top burrows
show up to get revenge by rallying the
public against Saitama for the
destruction of the city he deals with
the burrows and tells off the crowd
yepez oda a sea monster launches an
attack against the surface he's so scary
that if you take out the teeth it's
still a maneater
he insult Saitama and gets split in half
yeah yeah no literally he gets button
half bicycle beta is on his way to
becoming the useless I character of the
show a woman is startled and if you look
closely she says help somebody which is
just profound advice ranked a 11 stinger
shows up to fight off the second wave of
sea creatures while giving me a new
pickup line
my level goes up to Tiger and more
heroes had to join the fight stinger
holds this out but ends up losing to the
cking lightning max goes to fight and
loses but is saved by pooty pooty
prisoner who was ranked as 17 I would
put him on the waifu list by he has a
boyfriend and I'm a man of honor so hue
transcends to use angel style which
still isn't enough so now it's on
externa and he's doing well till it
rains the moisture increases sea Kings
power too much for Sonic to handle
wonder what happens when this guy gets
moist maybe he could have slipped
saitama's fist or taking more of a
pounding or a bird more means for me but
I guess we'll never know the sea king
targets a shelter where heroes including
stet confront him but lose Saitama
finally learns where the sea king is and
starts heading that way yepez oh not
Jonas gets there first and throws down
with the seeking a little girl cheers
for him so the sea king targets her in
spits acid like some shady which gives
Jonas the perfect chance to cosplay MGK
bicycle beta shows up and tries to
protect Janus and the people the people
start Sheriff Irma but all I can think
is this is like cheering for na at
worlds of course he's useless buddy
cells until Saitama can get there so I
tell me get Sucker Punch counters and
kills the sea king it seems like he's
finally gonna get some reputation but
some troll starts griefing saying best
Saitama is weak since he's a classy he
also says that the only reason the other
hero's gonna defeat such a weak monster
is because they're weak - Saitama
decides to whiteknight them and makes it
look like he used them to weaken the
monster then came in to steal all the
fame he gets a lot of hay and becomes
known as a cheat a fraud amongst the
public but he's able to keep the other
heroes reputation intact in light of the
event he moves up from Rank 2 to 1 and
after some tests will be promoted to be
class bicycle beta by Saitama so mozuku
is oh thanks for saving you episode 10
tornado wife who kills the dinosaur
monster with the meteor silver Fang
sells out and then talks about a former
student gato who betrayed him and
injured a lot of his students while
talking their something by the hero
Association and Saitama tags along we
get an introduction of most of the S
Class Heroes
hmm rank s 17 pretty pretty prisoner 16
jenos 15 metal bat 14 tank top master
maybe this one is in a douche fingers
crossed thirteen flashy flash definitely
not double whip their world swell
watchdog man for all the ladies out
there you know you are 11 superalloy
african-american luster and the average
American nine Drivetime eight zombie man
7 king six metal knight 5 child Emperor
not to be confused with Michael Jackson
or atomic samurai who I'm guessing was a
Hiroshima native 3 silver Fang too soon
that a tornado chafee Creek one blast
reel born by actually be 63 the one and
only well that took a while so I'm gonna
wrap this episode up quick profit
predicts catastrophe the chokes on cough
drop and dot's
catastrophe arrives have two heroes
fight a regenerating opponent on the
ground other half try to figure out how
to give him the ship while Saitama is
already in the show killing everybody
looking
the boss Oh episode 11 Mel's guard the
Burrow on the ground is ordered back to
help fight Saitama but he can't find a
chance to escape the heroes so they plan
on killing them with artillery metal bat
finds a marble inside of one of the
heads he was smashing and then destroys
it and the head dies he tells everybody
else about the marble and they start
searching for more Rudy gunship used his
rock glass which isn't very effective
Saitama uses underhanded grandma couple
toss and blows his head off
Mel's guard is down to two heads like
most guys when the bombardment is
finally ready
but Oh P tornado Chan sends off the
shelves back saving everybody on his
last head mal zgr finally connects
injuring silver Fang cytometry chah's
the final boss and we have to put in the
classics no powerfui through yeah c'mere
what's your wing uh emo
episode well Saitama scores off against
Bordeaux squall tornado champ outs the
ship with debris dr9 tells Janus that
metal knives his enemy and to stay away
from him silver fingers back in the
fight against Mel Z guard and is the one
to finally get a hold of the last marble
and kill him for good
Berto splits up a fight for almost ten
minutes max Saitama to the moon but one
side time I gets back he finishes off
botos so he mask is pumping out some
antagonist vibes at the end claiming the
heroes didn't do well enough in
slaughter some of the captives they have
jenos has tornado with a one-liner and
gets dropped metal nice harvesting the
chef to make new weapons so keep an eye
out for that in season 2 city a was
destroyed so they have to build a new
headquarters but aside from that
everything starts going back to normal
so a massacre begins popping out salmon
this wall tornado chance oh my hat
[Music]
grabbed Knight tells me torn nado cham
pelts what else puts up a fight oh hi
Saitama squares off against bardos wall
tornado champ eltz the ship with debris
dr9 tells Janus that metal knives his
enemy and to stay away from him silver
fingers back in the fight against Mel Z
guard and is the one to finally get a
hold of the last marble and kill him for
good Bordeaux splits up a fight for
almost 10 minutes max Saitama to the
moon but one side time I gets back he
finishes off botos so he mask is pumping
out some antagonist vibes at the end
claiming the heroes didn't do well
enough in slaughter some of the captives
say hat Jonas heads tornado with a
one-liner and gets dropped metal Knights
harvesting the ship to make new weapons
so keeping out for that and season to
city a was destroyed so they have to
build a new headquarters but aside from
that everything starts going back to
normal